victoire grandin bonjour bonjour bonjour
l'auditeur de martinique la première
candidats aux élections municipales et
communautaires offrant soit pour vous
alors victor grandin on sait déjà connue
bien sûr au françois mais aussi ici ou
là en martinique et puis c'est en
dernier vous aviez quelque peu disparu
des radars médiatico politique on va
dire ça comme ça
donc pourquoi avoir choisi de revenir
dans l'arène politique pour ces
municipales et présentez-nous
succinctement votre liste revenir en
politique non on ne parlera jamais de la
politique même si on se fait plus
discret même si on s'est fait plus
discret on agit autrement on travaille
notamment dans les associations
j'ai des forces de proposition pendant
tout ce temps là au niveau de ma commune
et comme effectivement j'avais certes un
passé politique
je m'attendais à ce qu'elle
renouvellement se fasse sur ces deux
dernières mandatures comme cela ce n'est
pas ne s'est pas fait donc je me suis
interrogé d'abord ensuite j'ai écouté la
population certaines personnes qui sont
venus me trouver les hommes il faut
faire quelque chose et je suis en train
de faire quelque chose c'est à dire me
présenter à ces élections de mars 2020
avec quatre listes son nom à la liste
c'est la liste émergences françois
émergence françois c'est une liste de
personnes d'horizons politiques divers
qui ont dans l'idée de redonner à cette
commune du françois un certain
leadership une certaine prééminence cela
place au niveau marvin gaye alors il ya
un contexte particulier quand même au
françois
c'est que le maire qui a été lu en 2014
entre temps
n'a plus été maire en l'occurrence
maurice antiste non celui qui lui a
succédé
monsieur lausanne ne se présente pas le
premier adjoint de l'équipe en place ne
se présente pas non plus alors est ce
que ça veut dire que c'est plus ouvert
est ce que c'est une nouvelle donne pour
vous non non je ne le crois pas je ne
crois pas que ça sera plus ouvert
puisque c'est toujours le même la même
équipe le même mouvement qui depuis plus
de 24 ans maintenant 25 ans qui brigue
une forme de succession et même une
succession parental donc pour moi il n'y
avait eu ni ta ble ment pas de
changement et c'est le même adversaire
c'est le moule celui de l'équipe
actuellement en plein oui parce que le
celui qui se présente donc pour l'équipe
sortante est le fils du premier adjoint
actuel
toi t'as faim c'est une affaire de
famille monsieur lagier si vous êtes élu
maire victor grandin quelle sera votre
première priorité une fois arrivée aux
affaires
alors il y a tellement de priorité par
rapport au constat que l'on fait sur
cette commune que c'est difficilement
dégagé est il faudrait envisager
plusieurs ouais il y a une ou deux il ya
effectivement un problème qui est
préoccupant sur le site de notre commune
sérum de l'eau l'eau dans sa dans la
mesure dans toute sa globalité je ne
parle pas seulement de l'eau pour les
inondations mais de l'océan période de
sécheresse par conséquent l'eau est pour
moi une brillante et l'eau c'est la vie
et c'est une priorité qui intéressent
l'ensemble des franciscains du duo damon
jusqu'à à la maire du françois
mais quand vous dites low c'est quoi le
circuit d'alimentation 2010 à chandon il
y a d'une part la ressource elle même
qu'est ce qui est dit à l'ats rosso
période de sécheresse ou savait que des
fois le barrage et en étant auteur de
continuité par conséquent il y a des
choses à faire en amont notamment sur
les rivières que parce que nous avons de
grosses rivières et des ruisseaux un peu
passé du ressort de la municipalité
ce n'est pas du ressort de la
municipalité mais si on prend le vol
dans sa globalité et qu' il y a un
problème de sécurité qui se posent dans
des
inondations donc l'interpellation de
l'état sur veut évidente voyait donc
pour moi il est clair que l'eau est une
priorité au françois
il ya aussi le problème de du
déplacement notamment dans le bourg de
la commune
aujourd'hui on en cette difficulté le
déplacement de la commune c'est-à-dire
un plan de circulation qui pose problème
qui pose problème parce que le
développement doit se faire à partir des
axes importants et l'accès important
pour moi c'est un développement qui crée
de la hausse le niveau économique
très bien merci victor grandin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions c'est déjà
terminé les cinq minutes ont défilé mais
oui ça passe très vite
bonne journée